Okay, so we know that the allele for HD, Huntington's Disease, is dominant. And
the allele for a normal brain, or NORM, is recessive. And remember, that the
recessive allele is masked by the dominant allele when you find them both
together. So we know in this situation with two normal alleles, that we're
going to have normal brain function. So this will not result in somebody with
Huntington's disease. On the other hand, we know that if you have two HD or
Huntington's Disease alleles, that you will definitely be affected by
Huntington's Disease. But what happens in our mixed group? Well, because our
dominate allele, HD masks the effect of the recessive allele, NORM. This
individual will also be affected by Huntington's Disease. So the answer is both
the first and the second scenario.